this is an uber but it's not driven by
some guy trying to make extra money off
his own car this uber drives itself the
ride-sharing giant came to Pittsburgh
for its latest disruption the country's
first autonomous taxi surface select
uber users can now ride in self-driving
cars with trained engineers at the wheel
just in case
of course if they do their job right
they won't be needed forever
here we go inside riders are greeted by
a tablet that shows them how the car
works and how it sees the world
uber plans to introduce a fleet of
autonomous Volvo SUV is early next year
but is using Ford fusions for the time
being they can explore a 12-mile chunk
of downtown Pittsburgh an area the
company's engineers quickly plan to
expand over bridges down narrow streets
around jaywalkers the car handles just
about everything though the human
engineer does have to grab the wheel
every few minutes the city of bridges is
happy to host the Robo revolution with
its promise of high-tech jobs and fewer
crashes than ever before even if some
people find the jerry-rigged Robo rides
perplexed it wasn't really steel it was
innovation you've built Pittsburgh
startups will choose places based upon
the ability to be innovative and there's
never a time that regulations come
before innovation you can't stop the
clock and if you demand on stopping the
clock all you're assuring is that
technology and those jobs will be in a
different city unlike California and
other states Pennsylvania hasn't
restricted the testing of these cars
which means there's no rule against me
climbing into the driver's seat
so it made that turn with no problem
little adjustment right there but now
we're heading over the bridge and I've
had drivers here worse than this
it's a pretty normal ride if you can
ignore the radars cameras and laser
scanners you sit back and let someone
else or something else take care of the
driving and no small talk required
[Music]